Thank You Catherine um so you nicely
summarized what you're going to talk
about so let's not make a delay and
let's see who we are so I am Anna I'm
working at the data scientist with the
mobility since last year and here with
me I have Florian
who's also working as the data scientist
from inuvik's which is an external
consultant also also on the similar
problems on the topics just to get you a
feeling what's going to come up in the
next half an hour we're going to talk
about a motivating example we want to
show you who we are and what actually
drives us to to make this kind of
decisions or data-driven solutions for
for the car market in particular we're
going to see some some theories some
background theories which is going to
help us or design such systems in in the
in the long run in particular since it's
a Python conference I would like to pull
up a actual production example how you
show like where you show how you bring
in all the algorithms and Python in one
nice pipeline and finally Florian is
going to take a deeper look into how
what can be done from now on so talking
about who we are we are mobility we are
part of ebay tech pietà consists of
several other entities across the globe
and Moberly is one of the major ones
were much prominent in the German car
market so we are like a marketplace for
vehicles includes bikes trucks or even
four-wheelers for common man just to
give you some numbers 13.5 million
unique users every month and almost 1.6
million vehicles including as I said and
we are located in dry London and also in
Frederick sign which is a motor Talk
office where we have two main major
office and almost 290 employees and over
200 um yes so in of X is an IT projects
house for digital transformation and we
are supporting mobile in in field such
as big data engineering and and data
science
and our offices are located in Kailua
Munich Hamburg and Cologne and Fort I'm
so crazy I'm sorry so yeah our actual
topic is my recommendations and if you
mentioned you would walk into a normal
store this example which shows some some
bag store you want to buy something and
you're not only seeing what you're
looking for but whatever you have in
your mind but you seeing the whole width
for offering and buy this it might be
happen that you go into a store and you
actually come out with the product that
you would never have even known that it
existed before so you get inspired by
other products you see you you see the
whole offering and you are able to
engage with the product and the same
thing is actually something that you
want to achieve if you have some online
marketplace right but they're things a
little bit more difficult so you have
way more products and in our case in the
case of mobile I mean they're 1.6
million use cars and new cars online at
the same time but actually will want to
achieve the same thing so we want to be
able to inspire users that maybe don't
know exactly what for what kind of cost
they are looking to to engage with new
cars and actually to get to find them
the perfect car for the life so this is
something where recommendations can help
us so we see on the one hand we have the
user benefits in the sense of more
engagement meant you get inspired you
get presented relevant articles relevant
cars and at the same time it's also
always the other side so you have some
business benefits like higher
click-through rates and smaller exit and
bounce rates you may all have heard
about the conversion funnel
yeah thank you but yeah we would take
questions later Thanks so you might
heard about the conversion funnel which
means basically when you have the
intention in our case now to buy a car
you are basically studying on our on the
mobile home page and so at at the first
stage and then the last stage would of
course be you buying the car and in
between you move to different stages
like you get a better idea you search
you view you might Park cars this is the
kind of our wish list so you can
separate cars and and put them on your
wish list and in each of those of these
different stages of course you could
also drop out and we want to support
users and inspire them to to find a to
get to get new inspiration engagement at
every stage so to actually show you
something how this looks like so for
instance this is the home and the first
page of mobile and there for instance
recommendations could support you by by
giving you not only what we have on the
upper part like some some search mass
but also like for returning visitors
based on their user preferences like
yeah what what other what cost would you
be interested in from what
depending on the preferences would be
know about you and also where you left
off so the next thing if you had now
like search for a car you get presented
the search result page and also at that
stage you actually we actually can
support you let's assume in this case
you look for an Audi a4 and you might
not know that that a model like the BMW
3 is something really similar and in
this case one could say hey there's an
alternative cars have you alternative
model have you looked into these kinds
of models they mate might also see you
well then also if you now like the car
if you put the car on your wish list
then sorry if you if you view the card
so you click on the card you view the
car then recommendations can support you
by showing you similar cars so so cars
that have the same attributes and also
depending on your own your preferences
to to inspire you to also look other
cars because you might might be certain
aspects that you don't like about the
car that you just viewed if you now
viewed the car and if you if you like it
you could for instance put it on your
wish list and based on the wish list we
then also can propose and do propose new
cars based on on the preferences because
this is a high feedback of of yeah of
the cars that you like and this can also
be used of as ya can also be used to
give you prefer to give you
recommendations so we see that
throughout the the conversion funnel we
can use and kind of live recommendation
to make the user experience better and
then to go into the later stages like
contact and buying exactly to have such
awesome product you actually need to see
what awesome things are behind the
scenes so I will actually brief you up
here to show how things are actually
working together so the the first thing
just to just to give a primer like this
is not going to be like a recommender
101 session so we would like to show you
how the traditional algorithms can fit
into our domain or our problems side so
let's talk with the the common one how
many of you have heard of collaborative
filtering awesome I can skip this okay
so let's see how it happens let's say we
have a car in our database and we have a
lot of users I just saw like over 39
house million users the kind of light or
parked as Florian said they interacted
in different ways with this car and
that's you who also like to view this
car pretty nice
now these set of users who are who are
interacting or who interacted before
with the system for instance
this set of people they also probably
like this other car so it's another
different car and now what the systems
mottely does is kind of find the degree
of similarity between these two based on
the common days or the common interest
shared across a lot of people and it's
pretty simple from now on you easily
just recommend this car to the to you
and that's exactly how collaborative
works bringing in the collective
intelligence of your users now let's see
a bit more detailed example how we
actually use it on our case here you see
some movies definitely we are not
dealing with movies but that's a common
example we pull up because you might you
guys might have seen this common user
movie example from n number of sources
so you have Star Wars like top two
movies and your Notting Hill and people
rated this in such fashion and you can
immediately see here that from the way
people have interacted with this movies
you can you can define if you can see
the dot okay this Star Wars and The
Empire Strikes Back a lot of people have
put a kind of similar rating so like
have have a common users who have
similarly interacted with these movies
whereas Notting Hill it has not been
rated similar way now given this this
kind of a matrix which is like user
versus item it can come up with
different kinds of similarity
definitions what's important in this
scenario is we are never looking into
the content of this particular items as
ice as I mentioned shortly like this the
concept of similarity and simple could
be cosine one could be any clear in one
or anything else depending upon your use
case now we don't have movies we don't
have Star Wars but we have awesome cars
that's how it looks we don't rate cars
also to keep in mind we are not
explicitly rating two or three to our
cars what we are doing is we have
different levels of interaction this
means that he viewed the car which
Lorient said so he just viewed it then
it could be a parking or like a wish
wish list which is like he said it has
favorite and then is this Mel sign that
means he contacted a dealer so these are
the different degrees of
likelihood Ness let's say that a user
can express with an item so you can
actually read it and say like okay it
could be 2 3 5 could be 1 2 3 this is
not written in stone so you can actually
have any kind of rating here once you
have that that that matrix looks super
familiar because right now you just have
that user kind user and we'll be movie
matrix once you know that it's it's
extremely easy to look into what we have
parked or what your wish list it and
then give you a nice recommendation
so to summarize it up like what this
whole concept of collaborative filtering
is definitely looks into the collective
behavior of people it's a very nice
method you don't need to dig into the
content you can have really it works
really nice as a baseline or you can
just plug it and play it it will work
really nice what's the problem cold
start problem how many of you have heard
of the call strap problem okay so
definitely what you see is there has to
be a degree of interaction could be a
user call star that means a new user
comes to the system or could be an item
call start like a new item is listed now
the second one seems most serious
because we can have a new audio model
released and we'd really want that model
to be recommended to use as otherwise
people not buy it but nobody interacted
with it how do you solve that so that's
a classical item called start problem so
you don't you don't have interactions
but to make this thing work you need
interactions with the items from the
users second this sparsity problem like
when I showed you the matrix you have
almost millions of users around ten
point five and like we have 1.6 million
items and everybody never interacts with
all items and all items are not rated or
like viewed by all the people so you
have extremely fewer data points in that
2d matrix what you actually is possible
in theory so that makes the matrix
extremely sparse and given such a sparse
matrix to compute any kind of similarity
would give you near zero results or near
zero similarity values so which is
really not helpful we'll show you how we
circumvent this
problem second it's a batch based
learning because you cannot just have a
new row inserted into the thing and you
can just do any incremental learning you
have to pull that whole matrix in memory
we compute whatever learning
methodologies you're employing so pretty
resource and super intensive okay
can we do something else definitely
before that I will actually introduce a
concept of user preference so a user
preference is basically finding a
behavioral pattern of an offer of a
visiting user and that's totally and
anonymous and so we really don't know if
even if Florian is logging in just
beside me I don't
I cannot say likely it's for ian's data
it's not anonymized so there is no ID
nothing PII information there and what
does how does that particular profile
look like you have his preference over
the variety of RCS visitors for instance
BMW his more 50 person auditor is like a
split it equally but to give you a
simple example for example in models
he's more into a three and therefore so
as you feel like you can define a
fingerprint of that user like okay
that's his behavior that's his browsing
pattern how does it help us in content
is filtering how does contenders
filtering work you have the same car now
the difference is we have all the
features of the car here as I've written
here it's a price 10k extremely simple
vector ideal it's like could be a very
long vector of all the attributes
possible you can think of it's a small
card now you as the user interacted with
this card just now we talked about user
preferences so the moment you interact
with this kind of a vehicle the system
knows like okay this guy has that kind
of a profile because he likes 10k car
and he likes small cars so you just kind
of copy-paste the user link of his
behavior like the car attributes into
the into his behavior now let's say we
have two more cars into our database
like one is a mid-range like like a low
low range car 6k another one is a
high-end Porsche maybe high-end sports
car they also have their attributes now
once you have this kind of a vector of
the user preference
and you have the vector representation
of the car features guess what it's
super simple you can actually compute
any similarity matrix on this tool and
once you have that you can say like okay
you can you just recommend this car but
not these categories this this guy is
more similar to his interest and that's
the whole concept of content-based
filtering how is it nice even if you're
the only user in the whole system we
still have recommendations for you you
don't need to have a collective
intelligence of all the other people who
are there or not there we don't care
about that
as I said it's like you learn from the
Preferences you learn from how he
interacted we build a preference and as
we see like he interacts more and more
this this vector of the preference
vector gets updated so that's a
different problem altogether so that's
like building his preference vector also
it's a bit difficult for like for new
users we for new users we have a totally
different approach of users to tackle
user Kolstad problem however it helps
with the item construct because the
moment you have Adi Quattro which is
released in the market you know its
features and if somebody likes it you
can recommend that car it was missing in
collaborative before this is a general
statement non applicable for
heterogeneous items because content base
since it looks into the feature vectors
let's say you're dealing with DVDs it's
difficult to recommend a cricket bat or
maybe a football to somebody because the
content is initially is not the same so
you have to have analogous item set
however we do not have this problem
seriously because we are dealing with
cars luckiest the bad thing about
content base is like low diversity
because once you have a vector end of
the race vector similarity so you kind
of end up with similar kinds of vehicles
so you don't because with any standard
recommendation engine is highly
recommended that you should have a nice
diversity so that people see different
kinds of things but still align to his
interest so that's pretty much missing
in in content disc okay so those were
the two ends of the spectrum what can be
done something better definitely
yes so now we have heard about two
approaches to recommendations and in
this section we show how we how we
combine them to to make up for the use
cases that we did be showed so again to
our to our actual goal finding the
perfect car I mean for her it's quite
easy so for fire firefighter it's just a
fire truck and okay so what kind of data
do we have so we have heard about the
preferences of a user about the car -
this is more than today's a
content-based part we also have on the
other hand the interactions of other
users so this would be then the the
collaborative part and we also of course
have all the attributes from our car
pools so the millions of cars on the on
the site and additionally we have some
certain requirements these needs to be
so the recommendation needs to be really
flexible we heard and learned about the
whole starte problem and this is
something we want to avoid because a
used car is not like you have many of
them so you have this one thing or a
used car and they yeah after the car is
bought there's no longer available so
the inventory change is quite fast so
the constant problem is actually quite
hard then we deal with a certain kind of
uncertainty about user preferences for
instance about new user and of course
also really real time issues you want to
learn the preferences of the really fast
when a user interacts to the website
because buying a car is like a more like
a one-time thing and then you might
return only like after two years when
you want to buy a next car and your
actual preferences might have changed
completely
so what we did is we combine two
different approaches into into a hybrid
approach into a hybrid recommender and
this in order to to avoid the cold start
problem to do to deal with in you
with new users and new cars in real-time
and the good thing about this is since
it's it's combination of two like
default and reliable methods the the
hybrid is also a robust and reliable
concept it's also easy to tune for
different use cases we have so we have
seen the different use cases and if you
for instance want some use case to be
more collaborative you could put more
emphasis on this part and less on that
part so it's easy to tune and it's also
what's a big glass in productions also
comprehensible and debuggable yet for
instance compared to two deep learning
which we later also go into so how does
the the architecture look like so
mention your your user you're coming
you're coming to the mobile website and
then a certain user your user
preferences allowed and at the same time
all your interactions for the right
parts are also tracked and stored and to
basically update your preferences so
that's issue if you click on many red
cards for instance then one knows okay
there's a certain affinity for for red
cards then this user preferences are
also using the recommendation engine
which then uses collaborative
collaborative aspects from mahute and
your user preferences combined together
to a query elastic search with all the
listings to finally then in the end give
you the recommendations and there are
different technologies used in this so
as associated mahute is used then for
for the recommendation engine is a
combination of Python and Java and over
here we have a lot of Hadoop stack with
Cassandra and Kafka and so on
so how is now the final the the the
recommendation done
so basically the two informations we
have so the the collaborative part which
gives us a similarity between the
different items between the different
vehicles and the user preferences are
used to to create a query which is
optimized based on a rock out score and
then what the practical scoring function
of elastic search gives you is a sorted
list of different scores and then you
can basically use the top end results
from this query to show to the users
recommendations and for one of this
aspects we would see an example
exactly so right now I would go through
a real example what we had to develop so
the task I was given was to find similar
make models I mean because we found out
like users often in the orientation
phase they are not sure like what their
they type something they look for
something but that's not it like you
might or you should give the users a lot
of other options like hey not just that
also consider looking into this kind of
cars so that's why the whole concept of
similar make models so make good just to
give you an brief make is like game day
blue Audi Volkswagen model could be a4
a3 Quattro so these are like the just a
terminology so the idea here is to we
have to find them
look into those similar models as far as
possible so that they can have a more
informed decision and in order to do
that we go through an example of a
collaborative filtering here and this is
not an example of a hybrid one but just
to show you like hi pop I turn and the
data and the whole matrix interactions
come together in one nice form so a user
looks for audio for just to just to
repeat myself like in could be like we
would be suggesting some similar
vehicles like BM 6 4 5 talking of Python
what we use under the hood was light ISM
and extremely nice well
documented library for doing all kinds
of recommendation jobs which includes
implicit feedback or explicit feedback
which I didn't mention it but people who
are familiar might take a deeper look
there's very nice documentation and the
nice thing is it's it has a C compiler
so it's really underlying it's like
almost see like speed so which is really
optimized for your hardware and the
awesome part was it's like using all
your course so you can actually have a
high number of threads spawned and you
can actually train models on like data
set in parallel also there are like lot
of objective functions to choose from
for instance here like patient PageRank
or like weighted approximate ranking is
there more suited for scenarios where
you have just positive rankings like 1 2
3 as we showed you can also have a
logistic where you have plus minus like
comes up comes down kind of data set so
you have a lot to choose from so how
does light FM and cars and items work
don't be nervous
this is I wanted to make it super simple
so we have a data set the same data set
and the data matrix I pull from so you
have millions and millions of users here
10.5 let's say and you have like almost
two million items here and people have
rated everything in a different fashion
let's call the matrix M which is like
Karunanidhi u that means like number of
users in your data set and cut nati
means the number of items you have so
it's basically think like three costs
through matrix the idea is we should be
splitting this matrix in two components
like one list one and another is a right
one why this matrix on the left hand
side M is extremely sparse we have
extremely less data points and I as I
mentioned sometimes back repeating if
you try to compute any kind of
similarities you can say like hey we
don't need some sophisticated meters
like this you can just look into the
columns from from this left matrix like
through the columns and you can just
come to similarity but again like you
have so less data points you will end up
with near zero similarities number one
number two this interactions these
collaborative interactions are really
lost when you see such extremely sparse
Oh
coming back to the age-old problem curse
of dimensionality so it's so huge a
dimension that all the real information
is just lost there what we do break it
up into a left and right matrix into two
intermediate or let's say latent factors
or like latent features which I call LS
one and two so that means you just spit
into two components so like letter and
feature one letter feature to what's
what's the problem is we are trying to
find similar vehicles so what's
important here is this R matrix here if
you can see the red dot so the the R
matrix is the most important one because
what you see here the whole sparse data
matrix has been transformed into a super
compressed having the same information
content but better represented and and
it's like considering all the
collaborative aspect of it once you can
look into those columns which are called
item n bearings during the keynote also
she mentioned about embedding so it's a
new it's nothing new here so it's a
representation of an item in an
extremely high dimensional space where
it is like nicely defined once you have
two vectors that's that's it that's the
job for light FM ends and you don't need
to do anything you can employ any set of
the I'd even with numb Phi you can just
do some vector simulation on top of it
and come up with a score and what you
see on the right hand side is like so we
have all this make model combinations so
we define every make model as one item
and we see like okay how did they
interact with this and what you end up
this like this n cross n matrix or like
a similarity diagram so if you have
let's say ten make models so each model
compared with itself so the diagonal
here would be like if you if you can see
it's a white line that means like
similarity one so it's like same
comparison like I'm compared with myself
so that's a diagonal and like the others
are the lighter ones are the high
similarity zones that are curved ones
are the bad ones that's it that's all
you want you want to have similar make
models so if you can look for you just
take one row which is present an item
you can give give me like a top K ranks
of all the similar items that's it just
to give you a sneak peak how simple it
is
can you read the left-hand side okay the
left-hand side is basically how the
lightest room is used just two lines of
code literally two lines of code you
just define your loss function as I
mentioned some item alpha which is like
the regularization you want to employ
and the number of components the most
important thing the number of latent
features variables you want to like blow
up on liming like you have the whole
left matrix M so you say 3 4 20 100 1000
whatever but keep in mind it should be
less than the number of items otherwise
you're not gaining anything and after
that you just say model that fit like
similar to any other standard machine
learning algorithm we have a model fit
it with the data you see matrix and
that's it you see it box which is like
number of data passes you need to make
and the degree of parallelism we want to
have like how many threads you can do
and on the right hand side it's a
snapshot of a MongoDB where we save we
build this model overnight and you save
this topic a similarity so the top is
the query item BM 6:05 which has a is
like defining the make model and you see
like with a score what's the what's the
similar ranked accordingly on the score
so you have this one this comes up next
then this we just pick you awesome
because the guy looked BMW and we also
proposed him or the MRC disband CLA
which is like pretty similar models so
to sum it up we solve the two ends of
the spectrum we saw an hybrid approach
so what does hybrid help so it basically
tackles three three main areas the
method is like best of both the walls we
just see how we just saw how we combine
both of them second the user gets a bit
of engagement he sees a lot of diverse
items he many visits on each of the
funnel steps also for the business it
also results in higher click-through
rates or not like lesser exists to the
funnel and let's see what we can do even
further sorry yes so besides this we are
also looking of course into two new cool
stuff and in the morning already we
learned about deep learning and how it
is applied in natural language
processing there are many other cases
could use cases for deep learning like
for instance helping finding skin cancer
or there's paper about and polka pots
that beats most humans when playing and
you all have heard about alphago which
beat the best masters of go and I mean
what are the reasons then I mean of
course after the hype about deep
learning but the actual reason one
applies deep learning is that it helps
to capture nonlinear relations it's also
some kind of holistic approach which is
also nice aspect we have seen that in
this hybrid recommender we are basically
combining two components and there's
different optimizations each part and
the deep learning you are basically
applying one optimization on a whole
yeah on a whole structure and it's also
less feature engineering it is also some
some of the big advantages that people
are always saying when referring to deep
learning that you have way less to
feature engineering to do because
basically the the network the different
layer helps you to do it and of course
we expect also to have some improved
quality so this is kind of the stuff
that we are looking into right now there
no no final results so what we applying
is just to give you a small over you is
Google's wide and deep learning model
which is also used in in google google
play okay which is I speed up a little
bit so I'll directly then show the whole
network just to give you an overview and
[Music]
this so basically we we still have the
the features of course we didn't need to
do some encoding for the continuous in
the categorical features and then we
have basically two parts that's why it's
called wide and deep model and the white
part which is on the lower what it
basically does it helps to remember
memorize really specific things that you
like for instance if you like this one
Porsche 911 so this would be the layer
that is really understands that you're
in this Porsche 911 and then there's the
deep components which uses embeddings
we've heard about the embeddings and
different layers which generalize more
so this card of the network would then
capture the fact that you're for
instance looking for family suitable car
because the whole time you were looking
for for large car cars which are really
safe and so on and these are in the end
combined to give you a probability that
a user acts like a week or Y so to sum
this up with recommendations we support
the user to find the perfect vehicle
based on the preferences and the
collaboration aspects thank you very
much and do we have any questions
I could thank you that was a wonderful
talk so if you could raise your hand if
you have a question and Jeffrey will
come to you and then we'll start there
as you were the first hand up and they
will move in we have about 6 or 7
minutes and then of course you can find
them they will be walking around the
conference if we can't take your
question this time so I do thanks thanks
for the talk so since you are using a
hybrid method between content-based and
collaborative have you considered using
factorization machines yeah in a way
with light FM we are using a
factorization machine methods so I mean
they ask you them later a bit about it
one of how often do you update
I guess the features per user per car so
the feature per user our direct directly
updated as the tracking goes in so it's
not really directly real time but like
depending on on the cows car like in a
five minute window it's it's updated and
the car I think they are almost directly
updated so if the dealer like changes
the price for instance then it ends up
in the elasticsearch also in a really
short period of time and then this can
is then used in the next recommendations
is the updated price use there's the
state the saying in Germany that people
like to look at high-end cars but their
budgets dictate smaller cars and that's
that bias the recommendations how do you
deal with it I can tell that so yes
definitely you're right but that's the
power of collaborative I would say like
if you just look into a lot of users
that contributes to really a low segment
of people and when you really want to
find a similar one they should have a
similar behavior and that's very
intrinsic within this whole
collaborative metric so you really don't
need to bother about however you are
pretty right we have other projects
which are coming like we're taking care
which is like defining those kind of
users who have those particular
behaviors so we can see like oh okay
this guy is just a surfer so weigh him
differently yeah you're definitely
definitely right exactly so as an app
has settled so you can kind of already
see that there's even no buying
attendant for those cars for those
people so they just like to to watch
those cars but have no buying intent and
then if you can separate them and do the
recommendation based on the remaining
ones that have a buying intent then you
can help to improve this that you don't
have to buy it
so my question was about how do you put
all this in production and actually did
you find any limitation with the library
that we are using with like the same as
for example can you fit the whole model
in memory in the hip you are using are
using yes definitely and it abuse it is
resource instant intensive so the secret
is there's this sparse matrix
representation in Python where you can
just load this whole data and it just
has extremely dense representation of it
and Union then you can use that so the
matrix to reduce the matrix is shot and
you saw in the code line where you fit
the lightest model that's actually
extremely condensed representation of
the matrix and that easily fits so well
we had like a 32gb ram machine so it
just takes around six TVs of ram I think
is doable I mean like for the moment let
me directly related to the methodology
but did you find interesting or funny
correlation between the users and the
cars what do you mean like model
specific or yes people like we found
like Fox wagon is definitely one of the
most popular brands people actually view
but they end up buying something else
often which is like Apple or maybe four
or something so there is a quite a
variance in the in the different stages
of the events when Florian said he views
did he searches it he parks it so on
different levels there is a different
diagram of the interaction so is that
what you wanted to know yeah okay but no
really to the users profile is our
interesting correlation between the user
profile and the car they are looking at
it's not really I mean always an
analytical question
I mean since the preferences I mean
they're constructed by what you actually
look at and then therefore you kind of
implicitly have strong relation so I
mean there's there's not like external
data used I don't know so it's not it's
not like a profile be sent it's more
like about your preferences it's what
you mean it's I mean it's not I mean how
would we for instance know for instance
things like your your income or your age
or whatever I mean this is not something
you give to the side and this is no
information we can then directly use so
it's not a profile it's more like a
preferences based on your journeys on
the on the website if this is what what
you mean because yeah there's like no
way of saying okay like people over 50
years like yeah but this is information
we don't have right so it's not like
people are saying I'm that old I'm a man
I'm a woman or something so yeah so it's
more like preferences of like really a
profile or something that for instance
Facebook would have right Facebook would
know a lot more yeah so no PII
information yeah asbestos actually no
PII information use okay we have one
quick last question and then of course
Florian and another here so please find
them and ask them more questions I love
that there's so many I was just a little
surprised by an answer you gave earlier
because you said you can recommendations
almost real-time but clearly you weren't
talking about the collaboration part
where year they're composing the large
matrix into a user metrics in a item
metric so how often does that part can
we compute it so the pipeline of the
requirement there was like we have to
come up with disabilities so all we
needed was to have a list of similar
items we train it once a week because we
assume like okay the the behavior
doesn't change so awesome if you
it changes and once we have it in a
database we can just serve them in so we
have a Scala service there so we were
hurry what's the most similar car with
model ID X it can return you the top key
result so that's one part of it and as
Florian said the user profile update
it's it's like more real-time and we
also have a batch component so it's
extremely complicated under the hood
because there are a lot of machineries
working together so definitely I'm happy
to talk about it offline yeah and this
is actually exactly the key point with
using and also content based versus
collaborative because you're right with
collaborative you would need if you have
a new car you would have to retrain
because you just see the number of the
car in a way right it's just an item and
complete entity for you and this of
course one cannot do so often but on the
other side of the content based so if
you have the features of the car and the
preferences which you can easily update
in real time you can make up for this
and yeah this is so it's done excellent
can we give another round of applause to
the great speaker
[Applause]